welcome to this video playing Matty
Matty 2000 from the UK listen was a
British flag okay okay I play this a
6-line the somewhat offbeat way to play
the closest anyway it's not that bad the
setup is a bit slow from blacks point of
view but white is also play many pornos
so it's probably an a playable playlist
'um oh that's surprising with Avenue
player for you don't really want to want
to trade okay maybe I should've played
Knight f6 first to a completely prevent
charity form interesting
hmm okay if I go Bishop e7 94 this may
be the idea to play Knight takes e55
interesting way queen is seven others 94
that's even more annoying okay let's do
that first and then think about it
97,000 96 jack hmm yeah threatening on
c5 as simple as that hmm yeah don't
really have a good movie em and I don't
I don't want to play let's say Quincy 7
this is so slow and it's got f5
that's not a good position really
Queenie to check very good news call me
okay this is ugly I know but the other
moves that didn't look great as well
yeah get the dark squared Bishop into
play yeah it's not comfortable with
maybe it's not so terrible maybe okay so
what exactly is it doing taking here
okay maybe I should really just stay
like one I just take him he needs to
take what the night I think otherwise
I'll take gt5 ok Knight f6 here Knight
takes f6 Bishop g2 i just got nine takes
h7 intermedia check
okay I cannot do anything else I think
I'll accept that loss of a porn with
knowledge and at least my rook gets
activated so that this loss of castling
rights is not so terrible quindi five
young activation of c'mon it's a I lost
the porn okay that's that's not that's
not great but at least the position is
fairly fairly active it takes rook takes
maybe a some some activity for the rook
yeah I can play all kinds of moves the
ship developed and so on okay
interesting but isn't this this is some
activity now takes and rookie five and
tending rookie to okay if I take that f6
to see managed to ok I take anyway it's
it's clear no I'm threatening King d65
so you must do that and let's see maybe
maybe this isn't so terrible I mean and
worse I'm not trying to convince you
that i have a great position but i can't
i can fight him i can actually fight him
i have four against three so a possible
passer and maybe i can i can activate
the roof here on the edge file takes
takes rook edge for to e4 or take those
pawns maybe
but even sure that g6 was such a great
idea to be honest got ok and now okay um
f6 king e6 not a problem should I
actually move the pawns or should I try
to enter with my rook yeah I can try to
activate threatening rookie form and if
he goes rookie wanna go look at four
okay now can't take it yeah but really
that's not just back here
yeah can it just rip nick this should
should be okay now I think time warning
mmm interesting didn't think about that
move at all okay okay okay I seem but I
don't have any any big choice here
anyway now but the earth bonus is rather
quick here he bungled that upper elem
what do I do wow I'm just promoting him
I not check wanted to switch auto
promotion bag on check check check check
check check check Christ check check
I'm not actually doing it in a very
sophisticated fashion check shut but I
found it at the end Wow a bit a bit
rusty um well I have released all those
Blitz videos during the candidates
tournament I haven't actually played any
blitz this was all done before the
tournament so for like three weeks
haven't played any blitz at least not
against humans I played once in a while
again the comp on chess.com but this is
not comparable really yeah I got in big
trouble here out of the opening ya hear
this divorce is probably probably just
bad i mean ok maybe maybe not terribly
bad but this Knight f6 first seems to be
better he I'm in Namie trouble I really
what what do I do now I don't really see
a move I mean I can cannot just come
back here when this is check very simple
and yeah can can hear can even take care
but this was the first big problem yeah
the cook yeah the computer wants to take
you for which is like positional
capitulation ok yeah this is not not in
any way nice of it some of the game
continued yeah i saw that i lose the
porn that I wanted to have some sort of
activity chatter look yeah and around
here it's already already a fight I mean
they are not totally lost anymore and I
have some some sort of activity of
course that I wanted at the end I sighs
quite quite weird but
yeah came of course here he needs to
keep rooks on and then it's still very
much a fight not sure is it a draw
actually I can get tricky for him the
king is very far the f porn not sure
really like has a pretty substantial
winning chances i believe he of course i
could have played it much better before
not even getting into this tribal
endgame for example here I think you
should probably just take or after this
take with the rook this is this is just
just better i believe i'm already back
fighting in this game but of course
white is better with the pawn okay
thanks for watching